you
ah someone with the tall someone who is
playing as tall so all right let's let's
try d 4 so this is a 3-2 time control
all right very cool my opponent just
sent in the chat here on chest hum that
the air the stream is muted beautiful so
remember that game i played against been
koji ah where i drop my queen yeah if
that happens in these increment games
i'm not going to be able to lean at all
on the clock so we're having a slob
queen c2 when i played this in the
similarly Iran this dream I played
Bishop d2 now that's an interesting
placement normally it's bishop here and
trying to get an e5 hmm maybe even here
also so Queen e7 can be played but ok
let's talk less and play more about that
might want to do this right away let's
go for it right away hang on maybe I
don't want to pre move that on pawn
takes maybe i play my night here now mmm
yeah notice I only did this move here
after my bishop was on d too i think i'm
gonna come all the way back if i do this
it's accessible to a night move here and
excuse me um let's just drop all the way
back i want to stand this diagonal hmm
yeah it seems pretty cozy to be on the c
2 square whoa they're striking pretty
quick there i think i'm just going to
take yeah let's just take bishop here
I don't see any problem with that f2 is
hit but there's no you know Queen here I
just castle okay I think I want to just
castle and on Bishop c6 I think night
here so as my this was my big idea here
okay this night can't move too quickly
either step it up a little bit be nice
to play where I don't have a time
deficit but I got that increment so does
my opponent who enjoys chess okay my big
plan was to just take that bishop but
should I even rush how could I improve
my position just a hair by ship here I
like my night maybe Brooke here next I'm
you've been threatening to take and then
take the night and then take the pond
with check ah so this is even throwing a
threat one that I didn't realize was
there so maybe they're going to have to
do some funky pawn move here or I'll
make a flight square right away and
address this threat adjacent diagonals
this is a more influential one it
doesn't get more influential than the
corner to corner one so now what what
would I do if I was playing black here
it's a bit scary for sure h6 even just
even if it's not the loss of upon this
idea of taking the bishop and then
running the structure this is a
difficult move to me hmm even taking
right away on c6 and then uh you know
and then following up with Bishop here
would have been fine I think although on
Knight takes maybe pawn takes and on
Bishop here maybe there would be Knight
g4 coordinating on h2 but doing in this
move order you know there's no Knight g4
stuff I'm on that square what black is
considering going here I could go in for
that pun it would be opposite color
bishops however maybe black is trying to
that position being down upon taking
here might be risky rook here Knight
takes bishop let's say Queen takes
Bishop takes pawn takes Bishop takes
King here with rook here and then stuff
against my king hmm ok so that's what
they're going for huh well what do you
do rook to one of the m.i.a what rook to
one of these two squares is what I'm
thinking one minute warning hmm it feels
right to get this rook working I don't
know that I want to contend the deep can
test the D file maybe I should have
actually yeah maybe I should have done
that oh well huh what's up with that
mouth all right let's see if i could
push that Bishop around just a little
bit I like my night you know he's he's a
super piece oh you know what I should
have looked into doing this drop my
bishop back queen situ I should be
looking to attack here and I could
remove this night another thing I'm
making way for is Knight g4 rook here
though I have this Bishop that sensitive
let's drop him all the way back Bishop
here maybe maybe maybe this wasn't so
good but okay we're gonna run with it
I'm gonna make it work hopefully 40
seconds we're even on time-ish uh-huh so
now I don't have to react no I don't
want night fa to defend stuff let's take
that Bishop now yes and then move here
the square that the night is no longer
there to defend so night here defends me
but I could pick up a pond at least i'm
sure i was just forgetting there for a
moment that i do have to convert this
it's thinking oh we're going to do a
time raise oh there's
Knight f6 too I'm not taking that night
though scoop that pawn up maybe next I
can threaten this can't take with the
Queen let's just drop all the way back
get a flight square in small improving
moves at this stage could do this if the
Queen or Bishop leaves this diagonal I
could get these guys working it's now a
3 2 1 majority let's actually challenge
this maybe we could get one Rogoff get
one work off maybe get a flight square
right here these bishops do well to stop
entry points like this here nice slow
improving move in fact I should have
looked into be for this wasn't really
needed ok let's get these guys rolling
this is where I have an advantage of
majority um I want to be so quick to
push this pawn it gives up this square
hmm so I'm going to play here make use
of that Bishop see to move gonna trade
more to 20 majority on the queenside ok
they're avoiding that wisely um I feel
like now I could give up my bishop ah I
don't really don't want to do that I'm
gonna do it just so I could no let's go
here defend that pond eight seconds ah
let's let's move now not here let's get
on this diagonal living off the
increment are we again yes we are I have
the ideal flight square for my king
let's just tuck him in there and a nice
light square he's not going to bother me
oh let's just back up I don't want this
guy to get moving pawn push I'll do this
let's get this guy rolling and let's do
this keep pushing
Lena's kind of cut out tough to get her
working here let's do this discover
checks keep on going here and i think
this stay coordinated actually I can't
do this because I'm in a pin now I
should have played queen bee three let's
give this check let's go back I'm going
to give that check again well bank we
bank some time here I'm going to do this
and now I could do this next because my
queen is protected maybe not best oh now
this is definitely going to be winning
could do that move you couldn't take my
bishop because I would promote and this
is the the homestretch I think they're
ready to resign their they resigned I
right Gigi I'm not going to spend too
much time going through these I just
just want to get a bunch of games in
just very informal stuff here Slav this
this this was the first thing I
mentioned I thought it was a little bit
odd to play Bishop e7 Bishop East Bishop
2d6 with this sort of stuff with maybe
be five or queen e7 and getting this
advanced in I'm not sure that's what I'm
used to seeing with the little
experience I have out of this opening c5
was the right way to go about it you had
to strike it my center and did a good
job and let me let me point out this I
don't know if how clear i was but if
black went in for this I don't know if I
would do something like this let's just
say it's the Queen keeping the structure
I don't know that I would go in for this
this is a little bit scary in fact maybe
a reason to capture with the pun is so
that there's pressure here if I am going
for this variation then maybe he's
trapped with this for one so I kind of
have to go back here into the line of
fire and opposite color bishops black
has some play against my king maybe not
so worrisome
King position anymore so I'd have to be
a bit cautious is what I'm getting at if
black did something quite natural where
did it really get out of hand well at
this point here Yeah right here ended up
losing upon and I don't know maybe I'm
not sure yeah but I'm clearly winning up
on here for some reason I was oh this I
didn't share this but I'm night here if
I take this is this isn't anything this
is a really good home for the king but
uh yeah just consolidating neutralizing
any pressure on the D file and as soon
as before got in then this was just too
much you know okay a good game
you